they told me we are really looking
forward for you to come back
and we know that we might not be here
when you come back to help us but we're
really hoping you'll be able to make a
change for our children
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with louimi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford let's talk
impact meet sevda mimet co-managing
director of cardinal ventures
sevda from romania is pursuing a
master's degree in business
administration at stanford graduate
school of business
and a master's degree in public policy
at stanford school of humanities and
sciences
as a knight hennessy scholar in the
inaugural cohort of the scholarship
program
she was awarded the 2018 10 outstanding
young people of romania
and aspires to help cancer patients by
creating the first oncological system in
romania
that will focus on integrated medicine
and genetic testing
sev thank you for joining me how are you
today thank you so much michael for
inviting me
i'm doing well saying hi from romania
yes all the way from romania well you
know traditionally we're both on the
stanford campus
hennessy scholar and for those who don't
know what it is i you're going to
explain to us in a second because it's
one of the
greatest distinctions that one can get
it is the equivalent of believing
of a road scholar uh but but obviously
much much better and but simply your
your background is is so so incredible
and your
passion for helping people around the
world especially
in the health systems and developing
areas is remarkable
and and i just love the journey that
you've had both in the romania working
in the medical field but then
transitioning to stanford
to continue the research and then not
stopping there but continuing to take
part as
as either co-president or co-managing
director of so many wonderful
initiatives one of which i love cardinal
ventures
so i've spoken enough tell me a little
bit about
about your background all the way back
from romania how do you get started with
this healthcare because i also imagine
that it's not the most common for people
from
for you know the average student in
romania to now go be a night hennessey
scholar just like it is from
any other country in the world usually
most of them are from the us yeah sure
thank you so much for asking that
michael
i graduated medical school in romania
and
just going to medical school was a
personal decision i lost my father early
on in my childhood
and i think what i wanted was to
at that time with with it with the mind
of a child to
prevent other people from um just going
through the same
experiences and yeah i decided to go to
medical school and
after six years i became a resident in
hematology oncology and rare diseases
so that was um itself a very
challenging and literally a
transformative experience working with
blood cancer patients
learning so many lessons from them
raging from ranging from
um just being a patient
just being i mean all of them were
even though they were going through so
many uh
things that were definitely challenging
for themselves and their families
they were always trying to stay positive
and uh fight and never give up so i
learned so
so many great lessons from these
patients
and i was uh truly blessed to to be able
to to work with these people
uh i worked in romania in the public
healthcare system uh
and although there are positive things
in
in the public health care system in our
country like the people
and the human capital i would say that
there are also things that could be
improved
such as infrastructure access to new
therapies or
more advanced testing like genetic
testing for example for oncology
and these were some of the things that i
would have liked to
offer my patients and increase the
survival rates and that's why i decided
to
come up with a solution myself so i
really
hope and aspire to to be building a
cancer center that would be focusing on
some of the things that i mentioned
priorly
so that was my motivation to apply to
stamford and to the night hennessy
scholars program i had the chance to
what uh to attend an info session about
the knight hennessy scholars program
when i was visiting my sister in new
york
um like one uh almost one year before
applying
and uh yeah i remember um up to this day
i was just hearing about how the program
is looking for
global leaders in different fields that
will be addressing complex solutions
with creative or complex problems with
creative solutions and
uh yeah so to me it sounded exciting and
the possibility to be in the same cohort
with people across stanford
uh to have that diversity and to have
all those conversations that
are spurred when scholars are in denny
house uh
yeah i was uh definitely excited to to
apply and
um after a process and an interview on
campus at stanford that was also my
first time visiting the campus
um i i was accepted in the inaugural
cohort
and i got the chance to to be
in the same cohort with 50 other
scholars
that definitely have been the meeting
them and working with them has been the
highlight of my
uh life at stanford
incredible no i i think first of all the
night hennessy program i i've yet to
meet a program that is so impressive
both on the people that it that it
brings into it but also
in the in the mentality of how it goes
about one of my best friends drew bent
is also in the program
and i think that he's one of my best
friends too
so so that means that we are best
friends by the associative property
right
but i i just i've gotten to see what's
been happening there and
besides you know the fact that you're
building in your center is one of the
most beautiful buildings i've seen
and you know knight and hennessy the two
you know proponents of this program are
both
you know legends not only in the silicon
valley but you know in
the world with the impact they've made
both nike and and with
the and with john hennessy with google
and all his innovation and computer
science
but tell me a little bit about the
program more broadly because i think one
of the one of the things that i love
doing through this show is also
exploring what opportunities people are
pursuing and what
you know i think that this is for
example a program that
it might be relevant for application
from a lot of the people that are
watching this but might not even know if
it's existence
so tell me a little bit about what the
night tennessee program is and and what
is what
tools does it give you know the scholars
as they go through it
yeah so as i mentioned uh it's a
scholarship program that focusing
on uh helping students graduate students
uh
around the world to to become leaders in
their fields
and equip them as you said with
resources to tackle those complex
problems i was mentioning
people from all over the world apply and
uh the cohort the cohorts in the past
three years have been increasing their
numbers
uh so right now we are all over 150
scholars
uh in part of three cohorts
and the scholarship program is focusing
on independence of thought
and a civic mindset and uh
being being curious and uh being um
dedicated to as i said to advancing
um different uh solutions uh
to aid our world and us
scholars fields they range uh from as i
said
um healthcare to sustainability
to aeroastro
uh um so sorry so definitely a lot a lot
of
uh fields and the all schools at
stanford are represented
we have masters phds
and yeah definitely regarding the
resources
so we do have access to a network of
mentors
that are helping us navigate uh some of
the things that we're planning to do at
stanford and after stanford
we have uh we have speaker series
where industry experts world leaders are
invited to
uh to talk about different topics we
also have workshops
uh we had very uh ones that were very
were dear to me were the ethics workshop
or
uh the negotiations one um and
uh we have we've been having last uh
last quarter
one on justice and social justice so um
definitely a lot a lot of topics are
representing trying to make the scholar
uh sense sensitive to a lot of issues
and things that are happening in the
world
uh also um i would say the the biggest
resource is just the
the network of scholars itself this
right these are all right
people that are so so humble but yet
doing so many things
i'm learning every day from all of them
um
and uh yeah so um
this this has been definitely an
incredible journey
and right now uh we will be
we do have some alumni who graduated
last year and
most of us will be graduating this year
because the program is
uh three years uh and uh
yeah we're we're looking forward to
start this this alumni base
and hopefully contributing to the
stamford community and
uh the the world uh um after after the
stanford uh experience
incredible incredible so cindy you're
talking about how
you know the the people that you are
that you're with with the network of the
scholars is really
one of the most impactful things that
you have there but you know
you think you're also very very humble
of course and you know
you were awarded in 2018 and the 10
outstanding and people of romania and
you're aspiring to
help cancer patients with oncological
systems so really i mean
i think that everybody there is lucky to
have you as part of that court
but except tell me a little bit more
about you know the the great initiatives
that you're co-leading
as a part of stanford whether it be the
cardinal ventures the graduate student
council
the 2021 global leaders and innovators
and human and planetary health fellows
so tell me a little bit about you know
your activities outside of doing
two degrees and working on research
how do you even have time to do all that
yeah
yeah thank you for asking that um
so uh yes i'm doing a lot of things
on stanford campus i'm trying to
manage my time between as you said being
the co-managing director of cardinal
ventures
cardinal ventures is stanford's
on-campus student-led
accelerator it is a non-profit
organization
and also it takes no equity in the
startups we're helping to
to grow um the program itself is
designed
in two cohorts barrier fall and spring
ten weeks and this
in these ten weeks we're offering
stamford founders
access to resources like mentoring small
grants
a network of alumni companies up to now
we have graduated in five years
more than 115 companies that have come
yeah and they have gone on to raise um
over 349 million dollars in venture
funding so
some of the most impressive uh
solutions out there in biotech or
fintech
have been spurred out of cardinal
ventures so we're we're definitely very
excited to be offering
new founders the access to that network
um
and also uh our sponsors and partners
are offering resources to teams to
grow their ideas and at the end it
culminates with a demo day that's
attended by hundreds of investors
we had to go virtual last quarter due to
covet
but we we've been having uh an amazing
um an amazing crowd at demo day and uh
companies were able to just go into
breakout rooms with this uh
with these investors and take the
conversations from there
and um definitely start conversations
about fundraising
uh so we're very excited about that i
this is not uh an initiative i'm working
myself alone but i
do have an amazing team that i'm working
with and um
i'm very grateful for for what they're
doing they're
um most of them stanford undergrads and
uh they've been working so hard during
the summer
during all the quarters um to just make
this this program in a virtual world be
as successful as as it was in past years
in person
um and uh we've been dedicating our time
to that
uh so right now we're in the process of
um
recruiting the spring 2021 cohort
applications are open uh so
um we're we're definitely looking
forward to to that
and uh to starting the program in the
spring quarter
and yeah and let's uh just for the other
initiatives
uh in the public policy program right
now i'm working again with with an
amazing team we're trying to
um come up with solutions for equal
cov19 vaccine distribution in low and
middle-income countries
we're working with an international
health organization to answer
the this question uh and with partners
in health and we're
we're hoping to to be able to provide um
some recommendations to uh leaders in
these countries
to to be able to make the vaccine
accessible
to to the wider population um
and just uh another um
another thing that i'm also focusing on
is uh another research in the stanford
u.s russia fellowship program uh
it's it's a program where we're working
with students
across countries um and uh definitely to
to increase research and collaboration
between scholars from both u.s and
russia
to advance areas of interest to both
countries
uh and um i'm working with a team of
two uh graduate students from russia and
we're
a part of the biotech of the biosecurity
and public health group
and we're focusing on uh researching the
biotech ecosystems in the two countries
wow and may that i'm just you know the
ev
each of these little snippets raises
about 50 questions that i want to ask
but
we only have about five minutes left and
i want to go back and make sure i really
understand your passion and
where you're headed because you come to
stanford
with the challenge of saying you know
i've experienced
medical school and i was a resident in
the hospital in
rare diseases in romania and i've
noticed that there are things there are
gaps that i want to be filling in
there's
research gaps there's you know
managerial gaps
and now you go to stanford you're
experiencing perhaps one of the most
luxurious programs in the world
with some of the most the sun the best
people in the world and your
passion is you stay there is to advance
chemistry research go back to romania
and and promote some new and innovative
ways that
this can be done over there why why so
first of all why go back to romania why
is that the passion to go back there and
do it over there
and second i would love to hear a little
bit about your thought as to the future
and how you see this as a greater vision
in terms of cancer research and what
needs to be done
yeah sure so um just
coming back to to romania and helping
the people here
i think this is um a promise that i made
to my patients when i was in the
hospital
and i as i said i was working with uh
with with patients that were dealing
with leukemia or lymphomas
a lot of the time i was reading about um
treatments that were offered or
that were in trials in the united states
or
uh other western european countries uh
so um i was just um
just thinking that i i would like to
to for my patients to to have access to
that
and uh when i when i left
the hospital to to pursue the mba um
a lot of my patients congratulated me
and this is
um this is something that i'm
i'm still remembering and keeping in my
mind up to today that they
told me we are really looking forward
for you to come back
and we know that we might not be here
when you come back
to help us but we're really hoping
you'll be able to make a change for our
children
so um for me those were powerful words
that i kept
uh with me while i was at stanford and
that kept me focused
uh so um i think that for me would be
uh to start in romania and uh help as i
said uh people here because it is much
needed
but i would also like to just expand the
model to
other eastern european countries and uh
why not to other countries around the
world that definitely need
access to to better care in uh in the
cancer area
one thing that i'm really passionate
about and i've been also
um looking and researching while at
stanford is
palliative care i think these are some
of the
some of the uh tools that we really need
in our country to be part of the
uh to be part of our public health care
system
uh and around the world as i was looking
uh uh
to other countries as well um in one of
my uh
papers uh just uh it is a much needed
um service uh that's uh that's
that's not available everywhere uh so
for me
uh that that would be one area that i
would really like to to advance
now is the challenge here mainly you
know knowledge expertise and
and building that relationship uh with
with going back to romania or are there
different challenges that you you're
expecting you're gonna have
to to tackle as you go over there
besides just gaining the knowledge of of
what
trials and what medicines could be
attempted yeah so there are so
there are so many things that i learned
at stanford and about health care
systems around the world
i had the chance in business school to
travel to japan
and see how japan is innovating in an
aging society
and also addressing chronic diseases so
they really moved a lot of the services
to
home care they really do have this
concept of community integrated care
where the community acts as the
main uh that's the main signaling factor
when something goes wrong with with
people in that community
so definitely these these are some uh
really interesting things that i think
could work
uh in in romania as well but
um challenges uh i would say that um
a lot of the times are just integrating
with the national healthcare system we
do have a universal
care here in romania but
i would and i would like my my my
organization
what i am building in the future not to
not to be separated from the from the
public health care system because
a lot of the people in our country are
addressing the services in the public
health care system so finding ways of
integrating these two
would definitely be be a challenge but
also an opportunity to open up
avenues for this type of partnerships
and definitely i think another one would
be just training the people
in some areas that they did not have
access to get trained to and here i'm
talking about nurses and physicians
so i would definitely um enjoy a
collaboration through the network i
built at stanford
and uh in the u.s for for people to get
access to some training
materials that doctors and nurses
here in the country have access to
i love it i think that the mission is
is remarkable the journey is inspiring
uh you know your humble mindset and your
the way that you're approaching this and
obviously the the mission that you're
the the mission and the words that you
carry with you
and the the you can feel the power and
the force even even through you know a
virtual zoom it's uh
you can just feel it and it got me
emotional as well so thank you for
sharing that and i
and i wish you best of luck in your
journey i can't wait to see all the
amazing things that you're going to do
both with the research but
also with the also with the business
side and and putting everything together
and
and and and helping people around the
world and i i really really appreciate
that and
i appreciate the inspiration mainly that
that i'm getting from this and that my
friends watching this are getting from
this
so thank you very much and the most
important question that i have to ask
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself yeah
sure so i think one would be curious i'm
always
curious to learn more and from people
around me
the other one would be i think social in
the sense that i love being surrounded
by people and as i said learning from
them
and the third word would be hard working
i think i
i'm always trying to uh to stay focused
and
uh yeah so um those would be some words
for me i love it thank you so so much
stay safe stay healthy
and i can't wait to see you back from
stanford's campus yes you too thank you
so much
take care